we are not a perfect country and we
don't claim to be you're gonna see less
terrorism if you have more religious
freedom give me another country that
pushes religious freedom or the United
States business but who has ever held a
ministerial on religious freedom before
this one has anybody Donald Trump may
not be known as a champion of human
rights but there's one in particular
that's caught his attention the right to
worship freely my guest this week here
in Washington is Sam Brownback
ambassador for International Religious
Freedom is Donald Trump trying to hijack
religion for political purposes
[Music]
[Music]
ambassador sam brownback welcome to
conflict zone thank you the u.s.
recently held what was billed as the
world's largest meeting on religious
freedom the international religious
freedom delegates were welcomed by the
same Donald Trump who said in 2016
I think Islam hates us and when he
became president a year later moved to
bar the citizens of several Muslim
majority countries from entering the
u.s. how does that help your campaign
for religious freedom I see it all is
something for us that religious freedom
is specifically a right of everybody
everywhere all the time and what he's
primarily discussing our immigration
issues but she wasn't even convinced
your own party I mean people like John
McCain the late John McCain Lindsey
Graham we were horrified by the
statements that this executive order
sends a signal intended or not that
America does not want Muslims coming
into this country and you can go to any
state in the United States and you have
mosque that are there and if you want to
open up one yourself you can do it and
the point of what we were talking about
when I was talking about here is
International Religious Freedom and that
is guaranteed here in the United States
and if you can't practice at the United
States you're well placed to bring any
lawsuit that you would choose and to
declare and to put forward that you have
a First Amendment right in the United
States to do this and by the way we are
not a perfect country and we don't claim
to be but we are one that do that we do
believe in these rights these
fundamental rights like religious
freedom we do practice them and we have
problems and they end up in the court
system but we're going to continue to
push these rights every chance in every
place we can but the policy was
condemned widely by religious groups
including the Jewish community the
policy of barring people from Muslim
majority countries was the the American
Jewish World Service called it nothing
less than a xenophobic Muslim ban the
intent of which has been made clear by
President Trump through multiple and
Muslim statements over several years it
that it doesn't help your cause to be
promoting International Religious
Freedom when you get responses like that
does it
I don't I don't care for those responses
but I also would stand for all of those
people's rights to save those into it
those things that they do and I would
stand for their rights to practice
religious freedom in the United States I
think you were conflating two separate
issues I think you're bringing in my
opinion of what you're putting forward
here an immigration issue which there
are substantial questions about
immigration and there's a lot of dispute
and debate about u.s. immigration policy
legitimate discussion to have but what
I'm talking about is a fundamental right
to religious freedom to where there
really isn't I don't think that much
dispute that individuals the United
States are all entitled to this
fundamental right to practice their
faith or no faith at all freely Donald
Trump has said we were told yes they are
about Jews the president's statement
last month to them that if you vote for
a Democrat you're being disloyal to
Jewish people you're being very disloyal
to Israel since when is it the business
of a political leader to comment on the
political views of a particular religion
it caused outrage yeah you know my
position at work is ambassador religious
freedom and that's what I comment on
that's the lane that I'm in and that's
what I'm going to comment on on your
program that if you vote for a Democrat
you're being disloyal
I'm not gonna comment on those one way
or the other
I've got enough work to do in this job
on religious freedom and anything you
want to talk about on religious freedom
I'm happy to discuss I busted a brown
back you said that you saw pushing for
religious freedom as a way to promote
other rights you said if we get it right
you're gonna get more freedom of
assembly it's going to be more press
freedom there's going to be more free
speech taking place you said that in
July
fact is when you drill down there's
little or no evidence for that is there
oh I did I do dispute that completely if
you if you look at this issue on
religious freedom which has been
declining and contracting around the
world the last ten years in particular
you see these other rights decline in
and retracting often religious freedom
or the persecution of people of faith is
one of those first issues that happens
that gets manipulated the most the
earliest and you can see countries that
really honor religious freedom tend to
be ones that also honor First Amendment
rights of free speech and of assembly
you can also see there's a couple other
correlations on this I appreciate the
question there are other couple
correlations that I think you'd be
interested in one is you're gonna see
less terrorism if you have more
religious freedom and there is factual
basis for that as there are for these
others and you're gonna find more
economic growth if you get more
religious freedom this is that's why we
talk about this and this sort of
foundational sense but in July you
looked at the United Arab Emirates which
you singled out as being one of the good
countries they hosted you said the first
ever papal visit on the Arabian
Peninsula and they've been stepping up
and doing a lot more so you gave us a
gold star for that this is a state which
arbitrarily detains and forcibly
disappears individuals who criticize the
authorities you made no mention of that
when you were giving them the gold star
did you I didn't have those additional
things but also fundamental things they
are they are but also of democracy what
did you think what did you think of the
papal visit for the first time in the
history of mankind to the Arabian
Peninsula what did you think what did
you cover it what do you think what do
you think about that people aren't
interested in my views well you think
you are my goodness you're putting them
forward right now jail for their views
thought about it well I think that
comforted them well let's let's talk
about what happened
let's let's talk about you you have a
papal visit on the Arabian Peninsula
that's never happened in the history of
mankind do you think that's significant
those are people human rights it blemish
the thought we finish the thought if you
won't answer my question I'll finish my
thought here that that what you're doing
is you're starting now to open up in an
Arabian Peninsula area that hasn't had
these freedoms put forward before that
hasn't had a papal visit ever happened
before this starts to talk about some of
these rights and my job that I see is
one that you're always trying to move
people along stop talking about
democracy let me let me finish this
thought here what you're trying to do is
to get these countries to move on
forward and that you hope that as you
move them forward on these things that
they will intend to engage more people
that have a broader set of thoughts and
that you can get to more of these if you
sign they're gonna do that the ruler of
the UAE his sixth wife is holed up in
London having run away from him
terrified that she'll be kidnapped like
two of his daughters well when they
tried to get away that's who you're
dealing with
he's got no intention of changing and
being becoming a democratic state and
you wouldn't this is one of the
countries you named well this is one
that held a papal visit this is one that
I went to Mass there in that country my
biggest problem when getting to mass was
the traffic
I wasn't blocked from going there that's
not true in a number of Islamic
countries where I visited and you don't
have the degree of ability to move
around they are not a perfect nation and
they have many things they need to
improve upon as we do on religious
freedom the government chooses and vets
all the Imams issues weekly guidance for
the Friday prayer service even informal
Islamic teaching has to be approved by
the government is that religious freedom
how would you know you guys didn't put a
gold star I did why don't you compare
him to what the Saudis do what do you
think
the sound is a bit late well no but
discouraging what must we well what did
you ever think about how do you ever
improve a situation do you just say
we're gonna stand back and we're gonna
condemn completely and all the time and
you guys aren't doing enough and we're
not going to talk or work with you but
you try to present one sure way to do it
but my cobraman is president of Freedom
House said the US cannot effectively
promote individual liberty human
equality or democracy by narrowing the
definition of human rights to exclude
broad categories of Rights or people and
your focus on International Religious
Freedom excludes democracy Free Press
so the Obama years this was being done
much better and progress is being made
yes you have you just know you're just
saying that the way of just saying we're
gonna stand back and be critical we're
not going to engage is a much better way
to go you quoting an individual that's
saying that that's the way to do it I
choose to believe and I've been around
and working on these issues for a few
years I carried the original really
international religious freedom bill I
was one of the key sponsors of that and
a Democrat administration that didn't
want to really see this become law and
since then we've continued to put these
reports forward we've continued to work
on this topic and I think without those
sorts of efforts you wouldn't see you'd
see further backside and then we are
today but I'm busted so I think these
are key things that we try to push this
on forward you let me tell you what if a
high individual told me that he was
ineffective I want to get through quite
a lot of okay well I mean you want to
fight so let's so let's discuss yes you
do sir you don't want to hear about what
direct ways we want to go at this I do I
want to hear how you explain away this
single-minded focus on Walter national
religious freedom and ask you how
discouraging you think that might be to
human rights of victims in because I'm a
knighted Arab ever
very bright man and you've interviewed
many people much brighter than me over a
long period of a very successful career
and I applaud that you know then that I
have a certain statutory authority the
position I am in is a statutorily
created position and it has a narrow
mandate and that narrow mandate is on
religious freedom and it's on every
country in the world except one which is
the United States and it's not on the
United States because this is a very
robust and difficult debate in the
United States and we wanted to keep a
bipartisan support for this topic if you
take Egypt for instance where Donald
Trump said in April that President
al-sisi was doing a great job and was a
great president the question is what's
so great about ignoring the escalating
campaign of intimidation the violence
and arrests against political activists
many others who voiced criticism in
April 17 senators including James rich
the Republican chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee to attention
to what they call serious concern about
the erosion of political and human
rights in Egypt but you think they're
doing great
your boss mr. Pompeo thinks they're
doing great how do you think he compares
to President Morsi when he was in as
Egyptian the leader of Egypt how do you
think Sisi compares he has tried and
tortured more people than mercy do you
think Jesse is worse than Morsi do you
not think so he's the head of the Muslim
Brotherhood
he's the Muslim Brotherhood it's not
that strongly reputable of a group but
you would rather have them in and Sisi
is that true people not being praised to
subject their citizens to industrial
degrees of torture yeah and so Morrison
was responsible
well mr. al Sisi was responsible as
Human Rights Watch said in 2013
for one of the largest single-day
massacres in modern times in a city for
which nobody has ever been held
responsible somewhere between 400 and
800 people died indiscriminate killing
by Egyptian forces mercy didn't do that
I think there would be a variance of
opinion of believing that the Muslim
Brotherhood being in power in Egypt is
better than Sisi being in power now I do
not claim I don't think anybody in this
administration would that Sisi is
perfect or near perfect by any means
that you've heaped praise on and I think
that once would that there would be
criticism and that there has been
criticism that there will be criticism
but there I also believe there are
people trying to work with this
government in Egypt saying this is a
major player in the Middle East and it's
some way that we need to work with some
ways when I was in the Senate I worked a
lot with Hosni Mubarak and President
Mubarak had a lot of problems and he did
a lot of things that were highly
questionable but you're still saying
okay then what's the alternative and is
it the Muslim Brotherhood yes that's the
alternative well I don't think that's
the right way to go
in January Secretary of State Pompeyo
was in Cairo
he too was heaping praise on mr. al Sisi
he said he's really taken to heart the
ideal of religious freedom and he's done
so with great power and great courage
and he is to be lauded for that the
facts are rather different when it comes
to religious freedom in Egypt are they
Egyptian Christians who are the largest
community in there is live in a
minefield of legal and social
discrimination you know I may be you
meet with more people that are dealing
with religious issues in Egypt than I do
I doubt it but I've met with a number of
people that are practicing people of
faith minority faiths in Egypt
and here's what they tell me that this
is much better under the CC government
than it has been even though you would
prefer the Muslim Brotherhood they do
not there is communal violence that's
taking place and it is very discouraging
they are very appreciative of the
signals that President Sisi is sending
from on time and at top and trying to
push they've very much appreciate him
dedicating and opening up a church
because of the signals that sense they
are not appreciated as well under let me
finish this point if I could with you
they appreciate some of that now I look
at it and I see a lot of problems that
are taking place we just tell you these
are these are not the sort of thing
where you you picked the perfect against
what you have right now this is a sort
of situation where you say this is it's
either candidate a or candidate B within
this and they would rather have the
current situation than what they had but
not right for respecting religious
freedom it would be nice if they were 14
churches were shut down by the
authorities between September 2016 and
April 2018 with Coptic Christians denied
access to them from prayer services
prohibited in one village south of Cairo
they've been waiting since 2001 to have
a church and last December they were
attacked by Muslims with stones no one
was held responsible when the Christians
have had to suspend oh yeah and all
those things ought to be addressed and
we put those four they got a gold star
and the Secretary of State not get a
gold star he didn't say I give you a
gold star and you did you look at our
report our Religious Freedom report that
the secretary issued on Egypt he saying
incites a number of these problematic
things he said he's widely taken to
heart the ideal of religious freedom and
he's done so with great power and great
courage and he is to be lauded for that
that's what he did say he also put out
that report did you look at the report
which very few people read
now I would dispute that within the
religious religious freedom community
this is the gold standard to use your
terminology this is the gold standard on
religious freedom the secretary of state
issued that report he signed it he cited
it he put it forward and he stands by it
ambassador let's talk about it I think
you should look at that report let's
talk about the u.s. attitude to human
rights because this is change truck
pushes religious freedom any more than
the United States what about all the
other fundamental rights well I'm asking
you this one because this is the one I
work on and you asked to interview me
and this is the one I know but the facts
of their country is that as give me
another country that pushes religious
freedom or the United States who has
ever held a ministerial on religious
freedom before this one has anybody I
would suggest to you there has not been
a single nation before this held at a
ministerial and religious freedom went
out to held one we hope people from
around the world understand but no but
you tell me a nation that's better than
us on religious freedom sir ambassador
but this is an administration those
basically said goodbye to human rights
diplomacy hasn't there no it has not sir
religious freedom a human right Rex
Tillerson the Secretary of State no he
didn't I said to every time a human
right too often promoting our values is
an obstacle to advancing our other
interests in other words don't let's let
human rights get in the way of a good
trade deal I may I submit to you that
religious freedom is a human right it's
in the First Amendment the only one well
but you you won't even admit it's a
human right will you admit it's a human
right
you agreed to answer questions I agreed
to come here and ask them people are
interested in your views they're not
interested in mine
well I handle one area and that's
religious freedom sir and in this area
this is a human right it's in section 18
of the UN Declaration of Human Rights
it is a fundamental human right there is
no nation on the earth that pushes human
rights of religious freedom any more
than the United States or then the Trump
administration does sir and you can't
come up with a single name of anybody
else that does this is true I wrote your
last one but it is true your last
meeting on religious freedom coincided
with the creation of a new Commission
this year to explore inalienable rights
in u.s. foreign policy is that right
you've said that meeting yes that what
your the last meeting on religious
international religious freedom the one
you held this year you had a new
Commission this year to explore in
alienable right that was announced that
was announced by the secretary but it
wasn't at the ministerial if that's what
you were referring to sir came roughly
at the same time these are very separate
entities but I mean you can conflate
them if you want but they're separate
entities
there seems to be a growing impression
that you're prioritizing religious
rights at the expense of other rights in
2016 martin castro who chaired the u.s.
Commission on civil rights wrote that
religious freedom is often used as a
code word for discrimination in
tolerance racism sexism homophobia and
that that worry is present how is that
that would that worry that concern is
president knows
no religious freedom again the space
that I occupy is religious freedom
internationally it's not domestically
this is a fundamental right it's a
fundamental right for everybody it
exists all times all places for
everybody and it doesn't impinge on
other rights it is of just like freedom
of assembly in the United States it says
it's if it does a person brings a
lawsuit and carries it on forward and
they have the same rights as anybody
else this commission that was set up on
the Elaine inalienable rights has been
openly
he's chaired by somebody's been openly
critical of same-sex marriage do you
want to see same-sex marriage banned in
the United States I don't have portfolio
there sir you know I only have authority
on International Religious Freedom
you'll have to interview somebody else
but at your confirmation hearing in 2017
you refuse to give a direct answer when
asked the state that there were no
circumstances under which religious
freedom could justify criminalizing
imprisoning or executing people on the
grounds of their LGBT status I'm not
sure at that time but we I stand for
whatever those rights are that the State
Department has been supporting it
supports individuals around the world
and their human dignity rights that and
I support those as well you don't
dispute on the grounds of sexual
orientation
I support what State Department does in
this area the area I work in is
religious freedom but as governor of
Kansas you issued an executive order
rescinding protection against employment
discrimination based on sexual
orientation I did because there was not
a statute that supported it and I
thought those should be determined by
statute not by executive order loss to
your bosses I thought you wanted to talk
about religious freedom that's what so
it frustrated Tomas last year your boss
the Secretary of State went as far as to
suggest that Donald Trump's presidential
victory could have been the result of
divine intervention that's the
Secretary's opinion you know I'm not
going to talk about theology with you
I'll talk about religious freedom but
I'm not gonna talk about you don't share
his view all you do shows I'm not gonna
comment on it sir I mean other people in
the administration have said the same
thing heavy base Sarah Saunders until
recently the press secretary went even
further God wanted Donald Trump to
become president she said you can ask
her about it sir I just don't have
portfolio there I'm you're asking me
questions that I don't have authority to
answer you don't think this
administration is in danger of just a
little too much piety and
self-importance about claiming of holy
endorsements for Donald Trump I I'm just
not gonna I don't have portfolio there
sir you don't have a view one way or the
other I don't have the portfolio you got
it you don't have to ask the press
secretary or somebody else that can
respond to those questions I I can
answer a lot of questions on religious
freedom but if you don't want to ask um
I can't answer them ambassador sam
brownback it's been good to have you on
the program thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]